هذه الصور للفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس
المجلس السيادي وهو يتابع مجريات هذه
العمليه او هذه العمليات او المعارف
الدائره في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا
صور مشاهدينا تظهر اداره رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهاني
غرفه القياده العسكريه وهذا ما اكده الجيش
السوداني في تصريحات سابقه بان البرهان
فيما كان امن ويتابع بنفسه هذه العمليات
وايضا هذه الصور مشاهدينا من داخل الغرفه
غرفه القياده العسكريه وتظهر اداره رئيس
وتظهر اداره رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح برهان لهذه الغرفه ولعمليات
العسكريه الجاريه الان في الخرطوم ومناطق
سودانيه مختلفه بين قوات الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه